this is launch pad 39a at the Kennedy
Space Center this is where all the
Apollo missions launched from this is
where more than 50 Space Shuttle
missions launched on this pad here this
is the flame trench where older the
steam generated in the fire generated by
those Rockets comes out I'm just
astonished to be standing here in this
place and here is something you might
not know the difficulty with getting to
orbit is not just the altitude it's
mainly the speed if you won't go to
orbit then you have to go 15,000 miles
an hour after getting up to
International Space Station height
15,000 miles an hour that's what both
stock fuel goes up if you don't have
that speed then you're going to go up
and you're gonna come straight back down
if you can't go fast enough to dodge the
curvature of the earth then you're just
going to come straight back down the
energy budget isn't just our altitude
it's on speed
it goes from chemical energy in the
rocket to kinetic energy as it flies and
goes across and then burns it off as
heat and friction as it plunges back
down into the atmosphere you're just
falling through the atmosphere you don't
burn up but if you're going 15,000 miles
an hour plunging into it and using it as
drag to stop then you get the trouble
with burning up on re-entry so there you
go the problem with orbit is not
altitude but speed and that is something
you might not have known
[Applause]
[Music]